remember writing it thickening i am the
composer of a song in multiple called
one shiny moment I had just finished a
gig at this little club called the
varsity in got done with my nights work
and bail it up for the bar Larry Bird
was playing basketball so I was watching
Larry because that was 8006 that he was
in his prime this waitress sat down next
to me and it's fair to say that she was
quite lovely and so much so that I'd
never spoken to her over the months I
played there because she asked about
what I was looking at and I tried to
explain to her about basketball when I
turned around to continue the
conversation she'd wandered into the
night forever
everything changed here we go in this
building and it began with Jeff Barrett
haven't I seen you before about 30 years
ago 30 years he looks the same put a few
miles on these tires
we put miles on our tires the last time
I was here was when Jan sat down and
inspired me to talk about one of the few
things I know about which is basketball
I knew nothing about basketball I did
not appreciate its beauty had anybody
less ignorant than me set here anybody
with a clue about poise or athleticism
or what happens on a court
you never could have written that song I
think I always like a blank slate
October story on - yes but I only talked
about it with her because of course I
was panicked and secondly I knew a
little bit about basketball Larry at the
time was in the zone and tried to
explain to her what the zone was and so
forth I realized the way of talking
about the zone is this shining moment
you remember what you told me forgive me
tell me what you told me there is a
moment and it's rare but occasionally
you're on the court
and you make the right step and you lift
your arm and the ball makes the right
arc and against every possibility the
shot works it goes through the net and I
understood that it's like poetry it
affect the words don't usually come that
way
I wrote the idea for the song and it
really stuck and I wrote all the lyrics
on the back of a napkin just literally
sat down the piano looked got the napkin
out you know in my pocket and wrote it
because my story wall affected you not
enough to have you stay here it worked
out perfectly